[Musik]
herzstück des ellis weltweit gibt es ein
bond gericht was sich schon einige
gewünscht haben und was ich auch schon
vorgenommen habe mir schon öfter mal
vorgenommen habe zu machen mac i can't
schießt aber aus einem topf mekies ist
so eine speise die man in den usa ganz
gerne verzehrt nämlich makkaroni mit
käse mit viel käse mit einer käse soße
und das ganze ist schon sehr mächtig und
schwer aber ich muss sagen ich habe das
ein bisschen
entschärft nicht ganz so voll fett nicht
mit sahne sondern milch mit gemüsebrühe
und das ist einfach nicht ganz so
schnell magen liegt man muss aber auch
dazu sagen dass mckenzies in den usa
eine beilage ist also man ist jetzt
nicht so ein riesen teller voll
makkaroni nudeln mit käse sondern ist es
eher zu fleischgerichten oder zu einem
salat dazu wir waren auch damals also in
chicago waren lecker essen und da gab es
einfach so ein kleines sondern wirklich
zurück ganz mini portionen matschies
dazu sehr lecker ich habe jetzt hier ein
rezept für euch was ich einfach für jahr
für den alltag so ein bisschen
optimierter habt dass man wirklich nur
einen topf braucht und das ganze aus
einem topf zubereitet ohne vorher nudeln
abkochen zu müssen wirklich ein schönes
wort gericht und die zutaten muss ich
sagen sind auch sehr übersichtlich und
ich habe die zum beispiel immer darüber
ich hab immer alle käsesorten und so
weiter harter käse ok den habe ich nicht
immer da aber alles andere habe ich
immer da dafür nehme ich 60 gramm butter
40 gramm mehl 800 milliliter gemüsebrühe
könnte braune flasche zum beispiel
nehmen 400 milliliter milch dann habe
ich hier noch gewürze nämlich salz und
pfeffer die habe ich nie wusste source
einen esslöffel paprikapulver drei
sorten käse nämlich parmesan chatter und
gouda und habe ich noch die makkaroni
nudeln das war es schon und bei der soße
was noch dazu sagen diese soße die ich
nie aussprechen kann
wusste schluss dass die sieht so aus ich
keine produktplatzierung aber ich dachte
vielleicht weiß man so etwas ist die
habe ich auch generell immer da das ist
einfach so eine würzige soße und die
schreibt man man spricht sie aber sehr
sehr komisch und seltsam aus worcester
soße die gibt es in gut sortierten
supermärkten und das ist einfach eine
kräftige soße wenn er die nicht habt es
auch nicht schlimm dann würde es dir
einfach noch ein bisschen mehr
ja und wie gesagt wenn ihr es schafft
gemüsebrühe fleischbrühe nehmen dann
habt ihr da auch noch einen würzigen
geschmack mit dabei und daher passt das
bild jetzt machen wir erstmal eine
mehlschwitze
ich finde das ist ein wort genauso wie
schlug sich und fluffig gehört
eigentlich ein wort wie spitzer nicht in
die küche mehlschwitze ich finde es
hätte auch mehr
irgendwas man könne aber schwitzen finde
ich nicht hin da können jedenfalls wird
aber das mediengestützte in der heißen
butter deswegen heißt das so ja und ich
immer so die grundlage für verschiedene
helle und dunkle soßen zum binden
ja weil dies mit schweiß für wind und
schwarz ich verbinde ich mit
ich hab dich halt das ist schrecklich
jetzt hier also das mehl dazugeben und
schön anbraten ist eine schöne
hellbraune farbe hat
je dunkler das mädels werden lässt umso
witziger schmeckt das ganze aber ich
möchte jetzt nicht zu dunkel sein
türkischer widmet aussagen und kein
billiger sagt kann ich drin
so ein typisches video wäre aberwitzig
dass wenn du schwierig das ist hier
jemand schneidet er kein teppich kann
und dann die brühe aufgießen schön
langsam und vorsichtig dass ich keine
klümpchen bilden
[Musik]
dann gebe ich da auch direkt die milch
dazu
[Musik]
paprikapulver und die soße
davon nämlich zwei esslöffel und falls
ihr diese wusste chance nicht habt könnt
ihr zum beispiel auch sojasauce nehmen
dies auf 40 und schmeckt so ähnlich
einmal kurz schön durchrühren salz und
pfeffer noch dazu
das hat echt auf ein schnelles gericht
musst du sagen
während das gleich wo sich hingeht kann
ich nämlich schon ein bisschen feldsalat
richten und vielleicht noch was zwiebeln
so und rob das wird dann das wird dann
richtig gut und dann
kann man hier hab ich zeit
habe ich gott ja fast schon drin
dann kommen hier die makkaroni nudeln
dazu
ganz schön durch röhren und dann las ich
die sauce mit den makkaroni nudeln
aufkochen ich früher auch immer mal
durch und wer das ganze im topf deckel
verschließen schallt dann den herunter
bei großen töpfen ist es auch so da
könnt ihr wirklich mit ganz ganz
niedriger hitze arbeiten also wirklich
so stufe 2 oder 3 das zieht dann schön
durch und ich werde dann so alle paar
minuten mal rühren das ist schon wichtig
dass sie das ganze schön durchmischt und
wenn ihr übrigens wollt dass die nudeln
später in etwas gelbe farbe bekommen
könnte jetzt auch noch ein bisschen
kurkuma dazu geben dann habt ihr so
dieses typische jack gelb weil ich habe
jetzt den teil städter mit drin aber es
wird jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig geehrt
wenn euch das wichtig ist dann wirklich
einfach mit kurkuma und
dann verschließe ich den top deckeln
schallt wie gesagt die hitze runter und
dann lasse ich es einfach gar ziehen so
etwa 10 bis 15 minuten bis die noten gar
sind und kann in der zwischenzeit wie
gesagt schon mal noch ein topping machen
schon herunter ich glaube ich mach jetzt
auch noch das leck und kumar drin
aber nicht so viel co
das ist sehr speziell
ok den käse werde ich jetzt noch reiben
einfach alle drei käsesorten
ich mache jetzt hier kurz so dass
kurbeln wir
und was ja auch gleich machen könnt die
nudeln sind jetzt eigentlich schon gar
als ich hab nach zehn minuten
tatsächlich den job
schon oder den herd schon ausgemacht das
zieht nämlich wirklich wunderbar nach
und ihr könnt das ganze dann gleich
abschließen oder hat ihn jetzt noch im
ofen und das mache ich auch gleich
[Musik]
zu sehen jetzt die nudeln aus guckt mal
wie schön
und haben wirklich die flüssigkeit
perfekt aufgesaugt und
da gibt jetzt die hälfte des käses dazu
[Musik]
dann schönen vermengen
eigentlich sind eher die nudeln so wie
sie jetzt sind schon fertig also das ist
ja schon schon sehr sehr lecker aber
jetzt kann dir das ganze noch im ofen
überbacken mit so einer schönen kruste
das mache ich jetzt noch und ich nehme
jetzt hier diese fajitas pfännchen
deshalb auch genial weil man dann so
eine portion einfach servieren kann und
ich muss euch sagen diese verräter
bändchen da muss ich selber immer so
lachen ich hatte mal besucht da kam der
daniel der damit mir manuka macht und
und ich habe gehofft eigentlich dass das
schon daheim gegessen hat dann kam der
mit einem freund und dann sind es halt
so zwei männer die könne halt auch viel
essen und die haben über hunger und ich
fragen musste und dann habt ihr schon
gegessen und er so an wir wussten wir
kommen hierher ich hab den ganzen tag
nichts geht ja wir auf deinen ersten
gefreut und ich hatte einfach nichts da
ich habe nix gekocht ich hatte einfach
nur noch reste dani falls du das herz
von gute restaurants und dann habe ich
so im kühlschrank geguckt ich hatte
außerhalb ist dick vom tag vorher da
noch ein paar weintrauben blätter dann
noch ein bisschen humor dann noch etwas
hatte ich noch ich glauben
kartoffeln oder so und ich habe immer
raps im vorratsschrank und dann habe ich
folgendes gemacht dann erwärmt ihr alle
reste erwärmt diese fajitas schälchen im
ofen oder auf dem herd und dann richtet
er das für richtig schön an und hat sie
das aus wie aus der sterneküche werkzeug
was besseres auto nonett gegessen
dann ist man reste aber es war ein guter
gast
jedenfalls kommt dass sie da rein
[Musik]
und dann kommt es jetzt gleich in den
ofen ich habe jetzt schon mal
grillfunktion eingestellt ober
unterhitze geht aber auch beim schiebt
das einfach relativ weit oben rein das
mache ich gleich denn ich werde zuerst
auch die zwiebel und vorbereiten und die
können dann auch so lange garen
feldsalat was ich auch noch
währenddessen und dann ist alles gleich
fertig
ich habe ich schon mal zwiebel die
schneide ich einfach in hall bringe
[Musik]
man kommt da direkt mehr drauf
jetzt so
ummantelt
[Musik]
und dann könnte jetzt die gemeldeten
zwiebelringe schön in der butter
anbraten schön knusprig
immer mal mit schränken und sobald die
so weit sind kommt es den ofen dann ist
alles fertig
[Musik]
und wenn sie so aussehen gerne noch salz
pfeffer drüber dann schmecken sie
perfekt
[Musik]
jetzt ist es fertig jetzt kaum hier
dieses zwiebeln drauf
[Musik]
und da muss jetzt sagen da brauche ich
jetzt niemanden beim video abschluss das
habe ich jetzt selber
soulfood ich muss sagen mcinnis das ist
die amerikanische variante von care
spätzle
mit den röstzwiebeln der hammer also
probiert das rezept gerne aus ihr seht
es ist sehr einfach mit nur einem topf
ihr könnt das ganze über buccaneer
müssten sich überbacken ihr könnt die
roche zwiebeln dazu machen oder auch
nicht probiert auf jeden fall aus ist
das super lecker ihr könnt natürlich
auch stadt makkaroni andere pastor
sorten verwenden dann ist niemand
makkaroni ist es halt penaltys und das
rezept findet ihr wie immer in meiner
app in der service welt apps kostenlos
könnt ihr gerne runterladen und euch
sogar eine einkaufsliste machen und
speichern eure partner eure partnerin
schicken direkt einkaufen gehen und dann
loslegen mit dem kochen also viel spaß
dabei bis zum nächsten mal und schreibt
mir noch gerne mal was euer soulfood ist
als muss sagen michael gees körper mir
auf jeden fall dazu
[Musik]